Hi. My name is Laura and I'm the undergraduate intern for Emory Healthcare Communications
Today I'm out on Emory's campus asking undergraduate students like me if they have gotten their flu shot this year.
Q: Have you gotten your flu shot this year?
A: I have not.
Q: Have you gotten your flu shot yet?
A:  Not yet.
Q: OK, are you planning to get your flu shot?
A: Yes.
Q: Have your gotten your flu shot yet?
A: I have not.
Q: Why not?
A: I just haven't really gotten around to it.
Q: Hi. Have you guys gotten your flu shot?
A: No. [Laughter]
Q: Are you planning to get your flu shot?
A: Yes, of course.
Q: Why haven't you gotten it yet?
A: Time. I just haven't found the time.
Q: Have you gotten your flu shot this year?
A: No, I have not.
Q: Why not?
A:  I just haven't got around to it.
Student: I don't have flu shot yet but I'm planning to get it soon.
Interviewer: Awesome. Way to go!
Q: Have you gotten your flu shot this year?
A: No.
Q: Are you planning to get your flu shot this year?
A: No. [Laughter]
Student: I did not get my flu shot this
year because I can't remember the last
last time I've actually felt like I needed to get the flu shot.
Q: Have you gotten your flu shot this year?
A: No.
Q: Have you ever gotten a flu shot?
Q: And ever you ever gotten the flu?
A: I don't think so
Q: Have you gotten your flu shot this year?
A: I have!
Q: have why did you get your flu shot?
A: College students are gross! [Laughter]
So I think that that what we learned today is that Emory students are not on top of their game
when it comes to getting their flu shot.
But no need to worry, there's still
plenty of time to get your flu shot this
season.
And as always Emory Healthcare reminds you to get your flu shot every single year.